so i've always wanted to do a quick
expose on this guy
uh on this ebu lathe character who
i don't know why he doesn't have the the
courage and i've said this before
he doesn't have the courage to admit his
stance like with all due respect there's
lots of ex-muslims out there that just
explain to the world that okay i'm a
next muslim now
others like majid nawaz and others
they for some reason cling on to the
muslim label
whereas for all intents and purposes
what they believe is nothing to do with
the religion of islam in fact
it's more in line with uh other belief
systems
or ideologies so why don't these people
have why doesn't he have the courage to
just come out and say where he stands on
the issues
whether he actually believes in the
things in the quran
as truth as objective truth
if you look at what this man actually
says and i'm going to put a clip right
now just to show you what i'm talking
about him talking with a guy called dr
hashimi
who is a medical doctor not not
necessarily a professor in any kind of
islamic related field they're talking
about their approach to the quran
and they candidly talk about the stories
there is myth mythological
and and so really kind of iterating what
the quran refers to as the disbelievers
saying
that they say it's nothing but assad in
the legends of the ancient
and they are nonchalantly mentioning
this and thinking that they have
a claim to islam thereafter that you can
say that these stories
these histories that are pertained
within the quranic discourse
are somehow mythological and then you
can come to a viewpoint
that uh that this is uh that
uh that you're a muslim how how do the
two things
connect that in addition to the fact
that you are a traitor to the muslim
community especially with the palestine
issue
and we will be exposing that just as dr
norman finkelstein exposed you
okay and correctly asked as we'll put in
this video
who gave this guy a voice unfortunately
was us that gave him a voice
but i think he's pretty much canceled
now and anyone who
who dares even mention this guy in the
public sphere as
any in any way connected to the muslim
voice
is only deluding themselves video really
is
a really good one if one wants to know
what the methodology of the two people
that you see on the screen
it was sent to me uh this video by
somebody and um
this probably is the most damaging part
of the video in terms of outlining their
own methodology
these two individuals claim to be muslim
they're still hanging on to a muslim
identity which
boggles the mind really why you still
claim to be muslim
after you take the views that we're
going to see that they take
in terms of the quran and obviously the
title of this
axis of morality and archetypal myths in
the quran
clearly he speaks volumes in and of
itself but let's see what he says here
some people find it interesting and some
people finding it as you'll get normal
questions
so now to come to the issue okay i would
i would answer a professor
not one of the easily some people might
be confused with so professor who was
the presidential islamic modernist uh
identified with that bonus uh pride in
that we talked about that later but um
he said that it's a very brief passage i
highlighted it and i started and one of
his books he wrote
the leaders need to stop worrying about
the historical uh archaeological uh
enterprises that are going on right now
because they're so fearful that it will
disprove the historical truths this is
the reality of some of the events that i
mentioned for example the exodus
so uh we are so worried that exodus has
proven historically not true
then our belief goes down the dream what
i'm arguing is we don't know
what we know for certain things about
mohammed existed that jesus existed and
that with jesus
islam he had uh the way that quran deals
with the story is in a literary way
and it actually is we should focus on
what the quran is doing as opposed to
just what it's saying so for example
when it talks about miracles what the
quran is doing is actually saying it's
really articulating the story for a
theological ends not to narrate history
it's saying that
yes jesus may have done all of these
things in your uh sacred uh stories
but really it's re-attributing them to
god that they did with the god's
permission
so if you take a literary um lens you no
longer have to say that this is
historically uh what the prophet is
doing
is doing it's re-articulating these
stories of different ways other stories
so yes it's a legend and legends are
usually not always but usually based on
actual historical figures
but certain things are dramatized so i
don't think that he actually uh spoke in
the cradle or uh
this takes him out the fall of islam
there's no doubt about it
if he thinks that i mean this is
literally what the quran is saying
uh this is literally what the quran says
and i believe both of them
fit the category they both do this quite
regularly
this takes someone out of the fold of
islam without a shadow of a doubt the
quran says that they will say it's
literally the legends of the ancient and
he's very
candid and nonchalant in his he thinks
he's clever but he really is not
uh and he's saying this guy here um
so anyone who sees any of these two
people
you should know that they are basically
not brave as the ex-muslims
who just come out and say you know we've
left the religion for all intents and
purposes they they're just people that
like masjid nawaz you know for some
strange reason
hang on to the muslim label so this
gives you a little bit of
who they are in terms of methodology
let's take a look at what this animal
has to say this pusillanimous this
coward
this charlatan this weasel
yes let's take a look at what he has to
say about
palestine and giving it to the jews in
his words
um i then would argue for a complete
exile of all palestinians
i would say that all palestinians should
leave palestine and it should be
facilitated for them i'm sorry by
palestine i mean
the gaza strip and the parts that are um
blocked in clearly by israel
now i feel that they should be uh
relocated
and comfortably with compensation and
accommodation and education paid for in
different parts of the arab world arabic
speaking
of course someone like you would say
that someone who's been arrested for
extreme pornography um we don't know
what that is whether it's bestiality or
child porn
because the definitions of extreme
pornography
fall into that and i don't know why
people would even want to associate with
you
someone so despicable as an individual
to be caught with extreme pornography
which by uk law this the standard of
which may mean that you
you possessed child pornography obesity
because of something like this
and you're connected with child groomers
and now you think you have the audacity
to sit
there and tell us what we should and
shouldn't do
with such an issue as the palestine
issue what arrogance
and what diabolical and embarrassing
you know statements that just expose you
further for what you are you're a fraud
a charlatan well so acclimatizing is not
difficult for them and they should be
set up as generals of clusters but kind
of spread out and there's many arab
countries in the world and i'm sure that
that
could even happen and israel probably
would even be happy to pay for it
because the amount of money it spends on
even bombing them is these things don't
come cheap so but the problem with this
look how disgusting how easily and
casually talks about bombing palestinian
people
well this guy's a joke honestly this
this guy is a joke of the muslim
community
for any muslim any muslim okay
who follows the sky i'm absolutely
disassociated
from you with all due respect how can
you follow a guy that speaks so candidly
about muslim suffering and palestinian
suffering in this way
and who is for all intents and purposes
everything almost the utters with regard
to islamic law is
uh islam outside of the scope of islam
this guy's a joke this dr norman
finkelstein here
he's humiliating this this charlatan
this academic charlatan
uh abu leith who he calls himself mufti
or he's absolutely not a mufti in any
sense of the word
this guy is an absolute charlatan and
look at dr norman fingerstein he says if
you give this more a voice to sparrow's
nonsense
he's either stupid or paid to be a clown
potentially both
and he's absolutely some of the things
that he said
dr norman finkelstein is one of the
esteemed professors
um in this field in fact his foremost
in this field he's written many books on
this
and he finds this abhorrent he this guy
thinks he's clever but he finds his
opponent
this um i can't stand this guy look at
the comments
this guy bolu i've seen bolu he he i
think he
he sums it up quite well he says here he
worked with quillian foundation which
as we know imagine now was except he
tried to prove his credibility by
showing up classical scholars and
selfies
after scholars got aware about his
heresy and deviants and lies they
rejected him publicly
and this clown on on side accused him of
extremism afterwards he is
basically means he's pretend muslim he
doesn't believe he's not actually a
believer
and yeah you know why not just come out
and say
if you are that why not just come out
and say well you know i'm
uh not a muslim be brave i mean there's
lots of non-muslims out there ex-muslims
be brave like them i actually respect
the ex-muslims more than this guy
i respect them more than this guy
because they just make their agenda
clear
this guy's trying to have his cake and
eat you both i am on the record now
saying i respect ex-muslims more than
this
fake mufti ebu leif